conmoción en argentina tras la
hospitalización y muerte de decenas de
personas debido al consumo de cocaína
adulterada en el distrito de san martín
en buenos aires- signos de shock de
presión sensorial dificultad
respiratoria y excitación psicomotriz
síntomas que decenas de afectados
experimentaron de forma simultánea me
fumé eso y me tocó la participacón a
dormir y hoy a la mañana no me levanté
me levanté con todo el día de 8 [__]
con vómito dolor en
el cuerpo alan sobrevivió pero no todos
tuvieron la misma suerte
la cuenta pero la verdad que muchos
jóvenes
tras los hechos las autoridades
gubernamentales emitieron una alerta
epidemiológica en la provincia de buenos
aires y pidieron a la población que
tuviera cocaína en su posesión que no la
consuma bajo ningún precepto
si alguna persona ha consumido cocaína
en las últimas 48 horas y necesita
atención clínica debe acudir de forma
inmediata al centro de salud o guardia
de hospital más cercano es importante
acompañar a las víctimas sin juzgar ni
estigmatizar por el momento las
autoridades no descartan que la droga
fuera adulterada intencionadamente como
parte de un ajuste de cuentas entre
narcotraficantes con relación a los
hechos varias personas fueron detenidas
en la villa puerta 8 en la periferia de
buenos aires causando la indignación de
sus residentes se llevaron a mi hijo que
menor
a mi hija
yo no veo a mi mente
no
ahora se teme que el número de víctimas
aumente ya que muchos pacientes
permanecen hospitalizados en estado
grave